primetime inside the trump
investigations live tonight at
nine. Dominion voting systems
wants top new Fox News
personalities including Sean
hannity and tucker Carlson to
take the stand in his trial
against the network. The request
came in a court filing part of
an unprecedented lawsuit over
what dominion cause Fox News is
quote license to knowingly
spread lies about the 2020
presidential election. Let's
bring in CNN media analyst Sarah
fisher and CNN senior media
reporter Oliver Darcy. Oliver,
who else from fox. Does dominion
want to see in court? And what
will the TV network will the TV
network for that matter? Play
ball. Yeah well, if this is
already shaping up to be a very
high profile trial, dominion
wants some of fox's biggest
stars and highest ranking
executives to testify at a
potential trial in just a few
weeks, and those include people
like Sean hannity, tucker
Carlson, but also Maria
bartiromo. Suzanne Scott, the
Fox News CEO, Fox News president
J. Wallace Fox News host Bret
bear and a list of other star
personalities and high ranking
executive at the company. Now
we'll see if Fox News allows
some of these people to testify
. They have signaled that they
do want to call people
themselves like Suzanne Scott,
the Fox News CEO to the stand,
obviously, for very different
reasons than why dominion would
want to call them and foxes a
shirt to ah, the present legal
challenges to dominion calling
some of these witnesses. We
don't know how the judge will
rule on this, but this is for
sure shaping up well to be a
very high profile trial in a few
weeks. $0.6 billion lawsuit
against fox any chance Sarah
that Rupert Murdoch himself
could be called to testify. Well
that's the big question right
now. Wolf the judge said that he
received a letter from fox's
lawyers that basically said that
Murdoch himself probably
couldn't travel the lawyers and
clarified and said, look, we're
not saying that he physically
can't travel but that there's no
need to bring him in again. The
judge had addressed that
physically can't travel thing by
basically arguing. Look we've
seen Rupert Murdoch up out and
about in various reports. You
remember seeing him at the super
bowl with the Elon Musk. He just
had an engagement party
recently, but ultimately whether
or not he pushes Murdoch to come
to the stand. It will be the big
question because lawyers from
both sides are trying to figure
out how they're going to
maneuver their legal cases ahead
of April 17th. And of course,
the murdochs would be the
linchpin of any major trial
heading into next month. Oliver
I'm anxious to get your
assessment on Rupert Murdoch and
this case, what do you think?
Rupert Murdoch is very important
. Obviously at fox, the buck
stops with Rupert Murdoch, and
he has said things like the fact
that he said some of his top
hosts like Sean hannity endorsed
election lies, which is
obviously very different than
covering them as a journalist.
Endorsing it means something
totally different. And so I
think the dominion is going to
want to bring him to the stand.
They've expressed interest in
doing that. And it seems from
everything we've heard from the
judge that he might be compelled